The opening trap for Saw 5 is the Pendulum,
the imitation Jigsaw trap created by Mark
Hoffman to execute his sister’s killer.
Like many Jigsaw traps, Hoffman would take
inspiration from a historical torture device
and add a modern element using machinery.
There’s some debate as to whether or not
The Pendulum was actually used to scare or
torture prisoners of the Spanish Inquisition
in the 18th Century, but we can say with certainty
that it was used by Edgar Allen Poe in his
fictional story, The Pit and The Pendulum.
In fact, almost all of the traps in Saw 5
have ties to uncivilized methods of enforcing
justice and the end of the movie would bring
the connection to The Pit and The Pendulum
back, front and center, so stick around to
the end of this video to find out why.
Welcome back to Things You Missed, and welcome
back to my Saw series.
If you want to see all 171 Things You Missed
in Saws 1-4, click here.
Saw 5 would continue the tradition of not
bringing in anyone with any experience directing
a major studio movie, by hiring the production
designer of the last three movies, David Hackl.
As you might expect, this resulted in a lot
of Easter Eggs hidden in the actual set.
Maybe more than ever before, so let's take
a look at some Things You Missed.
After the introduction with The Pendulum Trap,
we are finally shown the aftermath of the
Gideon Meat Packing Plant games of Saw 3 and
4.
Agent Strahm ends up locked in the operation
room, and is only able to find his way out
with the aid of some glow in the dark paint
pointing out a secret door.
This is kind of a combination of the glow
in the dark paint illuminating the breakable
wall in Saw 1 and the cracks at the edge of
the trap door revealing an exit in Saw 2.
Strahm then finds himself in The Water Cube
trap, and has to use the only thing he has
on him, his pen, to perform a tracheotomy.
This was really well set up in Saw 4, where
Strahm was seen constantly fidgeting with
the pen.
To Hoffman’s surprise, he makes it out of
the building alive, and on the ambulance is
what I believe is the first example where
we clearly see the state license plate, and
the nickname of their state is: The Fairweather
State.
Throughout this series I’ve talked about
how I think Saw takes place in a fictional
state in the Northeast United States and the
plate does kind of look like New Jersey.
Additionally, when we see the inside of the
FBI headquarters, the words, “Eastern Surveillance”
are written on a window as if to suggest Jigsaw’s
city is on the east coast, and a line from
Brit Stevenson later on could be alluding
to the fact that she works nearby in New York City.
"No I'm not.
I build condos in one of the most densely
populated cities in the country.”
The FBI has offices in both Newark and New
York, and Agent Strahm’s phone number has
a 212 area code, meaning he could be from
the nearby city of New York.
As Jill Tuck waits to meet with her ex-husband’s
executor, a woman in the waiting room reads
a magazine about John Kramer, with articles
written by Elis Lam and Nate Richmond, which
are both Easter Eggs for crew members on Saw
5.
Nate Richmond was a production assistant,
and Elis Lam was the art director.
As far as characters who never appear on screen,
Elis’s is one of the biggest, because she
not only wrote this magazine article, but
also the newspaper article announcing Jigsaw’s
death, the article about the death of Hoffman’s
sister, another article about Angelina’s
murder, and the one about the death of her
killer, Seth Baxter.
But there are a couple unseen easter egg characters
that are even more interesting than Elis.
You may remember Sean Scoffield, the graphic
designer who put his name on the fingerprint
analysis report in Saw 4.
For Saw 5, he was promoted to First Assistant
Art Director, so he got to put his name in
there even more.
He seems to have helped prepare these probable
victim binders, along with Stephanie Woloshyn.
In the real world, Stephanie is a production
assistant, but in the Saw world she’s an
FBI agent living a double life as an investigative
journalist for The Herald, the same newspaper
that Charles Salomon also writes for.
“I’m an investigative journalist for The
Herald.”
I can’t imagine the FBI is too happy about
one of their agents publishing information
about the same cases that they are investigating
in a public newspaper, but for our purposes,
Stephanie’s information answers a big question
about the link between John Kramer and Hoffman.
How did John find out about Hoffman before
The Pendulum if The Pendulum was Hoffman’s
first attempt at a trap?
It seems that before killing Angelina, Seth
Baxter was involved in a drug charge, so he
probably had ties to Jill’s drug clinic
like so many of Jigsaw’s victims did.
So John would have been watching Seth around
the time he took out Hoffman’s sister, and
when Seth went to prison for it, John switched
his focus to Hoffman.
The lore you can discover in the newspapers
in this series is just so interesting to me
for some reason; I guess I feel like I’m
getting extra content somehow.
For example, Sean Scoffield may have also
had a second job outside the FBI, though it’s
kind of hard to tell on this one.
It might say Sean Medfield.
We’ll have to revisit this one if they ever
release the movies in 4K… or we could just
not do that because no one cares.
I like how there’s a level of consistency
when building the Saw world.
When Strahm is clicking through the headlines,
the publications are many of the same ones
we’ve seen in previous movies.
It’s also amazing how so many of these Jigsaw
articles all use this same picture, which
is really just a screenshot from Saw 1.
Heck I even used it in my Things You Missed
thumbnail.
It’s a good picture, Billy should make it
his Twitter avatar.
He’d fit right in on that website considering
he’s a puppet.
When Jill watches the tape left behind for
her by John, you can tell it was made in the
operating room from Saw 3 while John still
has his hair, but does not have the bruises
given to him by Matthews anymore, which means he probably recorded this shortly before the Gideon Meat
Packing Plant games of 2006.
This is important, because it shows us how
late in his life John began to have remorse
about the way his marriage ended.
With the discovery of John’s body, a ceremony
is held at the police station to honor the
fallen officers in this case, and to promote
Hoffman to deputy-lieutenant.
“But today I’d like to offer a special
honor to the Detective who’s been on this
case right from the beginning.”
Wait… hold on, if you’re honoring Hoffman
for being there from the beginning, what about Fisk?
According to the FBI’s records, Fisk has
actually been on the task force longer than Hoffman.
I know Hoffman probably gets some credit for
saving that girl, but as far as we know, Fisk
has a much cleaner record than Hoffman.
He doesn’t even get honored at all.
He just has to sit there.
Hashtag justice for Fisk!
Also, we get our first look at Pamela Jenkins,
who would play a bigger role, but not until
the next movie.
Foreshadowing!
When Hoffman gives his speech, he talks about
cherishing life and bringing justice, which
could be what you want to hear from your new
lieutenant, but also happens to be Jigsaw’s
motto, and Hoffman would be the one to carry
out Jigsaw’s work.
Justice would be the key theme in the main
game of Saw 5, and each trap was carefully
chosen to be symbolic of this idea.
“We both deserve to be here.”
Strahm, or as those close to him call him,
Peter, is ordered off of the Jigsaw case by
his superior, J Jonah Jameson.
“Hoffman!”
And Hoffman begins leaving breadcrumbs to
make Agent Jameson…
I mean, Erickson, put the pieces together
that maybe Peter is Spiderman.
I mean, Jigsaw.
Hoffman goes back to his new lair to check
on the next game, and we see how much he’s
learned from Jigsaw based on the way he decorates
the place.
The anatomical human drawings call back to
the diagrams from the operation room.
One of them is a copy of the vascular system
diagram from the Spike Trap in Saw 4.
The miniature version of the game was also
used by John to plot out the details of the
Bathroom game.
This game would be known as the Fatal Five’s
trial, and because it was being held this
time by Hoffman, a police officer who is obsessed
with justice after feeling his sister’s
killer was not properly punished, each trap
resembles an old, outdated criminal execution
method.
And yes, to be entirely clear, this game was
mapped out by John, but Hoffman was still
the one to put everything into motion, so
I think the symbolism is still valid.
The first room is an update on a device tracing
back to France during the times of the French
Revolution.
The guillotine was used to behead its victims,
but this version implemented a system of tension
wires to force the participants to work together
in order for them all to survive.
Instead of the typical shape for a guillotine,
these blades all have a V-shape, which may
be on purpose to stay on theme with the roman
numeral representing the fifth movie.
There are also five participants in this game
and I don’t think that is an accident.
The second room requires the victims to find
keys that give them access to these safety
chambers.
The name of the game is inclusion.
There aren’t enough chambers to protect
everybody, so in order for everyone to survive,
someone would have had to invite another into
their chamber.
The Salem Witch Trials were a series of hearings
that outcast supposed witches from society
in the 1600s, and like the unlucky loser who
was outcast in this room, they would meet
a fiery fate.
I guess this is Saw 5’s Pig Vat in the sense
that… it’s pretty metal.
*METAL MUSIC*
“Yeah.
It is actually.”
“Metal.”
The third room contained the electric bathtub,
which represented another American execution
method: The Electric Chair, which was created
in the 1880s in Buffalo, NY; not too far away
from where I think Saw takes place.
Again, this one was designed for each of the
five of them to work together by dividing
up the voltage rather than having one person
take on the full shock.
The last room represents human sacrifice,
which I don’t think we can trace back to
one specific era or culture, but again is
designed for them to work together, by each
sacrificing a smaller amount of blood.
Of course, that doesn’t happen, because
there are only two of them left at this point,
so here’s what I would have done.
They had to fill this beaker up with blood
to a certain point in order to win the game.
There is a grate blocking the way, so you
can’t just drop stuff directly in the beaker,
it has to be a liquid.
The door to the bathtub room was still open
after they cleared it.
So I would take off my shirt, dip it in the
tub until it’s soaking wet, then ball it
up and squeeze out the water above the beaker.
They probably could have filled it most of
the way up like that.
It’s not until the end that they realize
what Jigsaw was trying to tell them from the
beginning, that they need to work together.
“Today, this singular way of thinking will
be put to the test.
Today, five will become one, with the common
goal of survival.”
But while “Hoffman” executes the Fatal
Five’s game, Strahm follows the trail of Hoffman.
In one scene at the FBI headquarters, we actually
see someone studying audio waveforms, something
that would come back in the next movie.
There’s also a name randomly written on
an FBI bulletin board: Tom Vencelides.
He’s the assistant production manager on
Saw 5.
The police station also has another more crew-reference
easter egg, a box in the background here contains
the name Sorin Popescu, who is the first assistant
art director.
As Strahm gets closer and closer to discovering
the truth about Hoffman, we learn more and
more about Hoffman’s past and how he came
to be involved with Jigsaw.
It starts after he conducted the Pendulum
trap one day at his apartment complex, when
he bumps into this stereotypical girl who
probably watches my videos, and follows his
journey through the building.
He hears what he thinks is a dispute and approaches
with his gun out.
It turns out to only be this lady with her
dog, but I think the scene does a good job
of illustrating what kind of cop Hoffman is.
This trait would be explored again in Saw
7.
Yeah I prefer to call it Saw 7.
Because it’s very difficult to watch it
in 3D anymore.
And also it’s not the final chapter anymore,
so I don’t call it that either.
Finally, he gets to the elevator, where he’s
gotta get out of the way of this lady, and
these dudes who are probably on their way
to go meet up with FoundFlix at the Papa Roach
concert.
So it ends up being just Hoffman and John
in the elevator, and since this scene takes
place shortly before the events of Saw 1,
John is seen wearing the leather gloves that
were a big part of the first movie, but weren’t
really used in the Bousman films.
Some say those gloves are an homage to Italian
horror director Dario Argento, who has a movie
called Deep Red where the bad guy has these
leather gloves.
I mean I guess it could be an intentional
reference, but it could just as easily be
not that.
“Hoffman!”
He wakes up in John’s workshop in this spectacularly
uncreative trap, but one thing I did notice
was an early version of the death collar from
Saw 3.
In that movie, Amanda claims she built the
collar, so maybe she physically built it off
of one of John’s prototype designs.
When John details the rules of the game to
Hoffman, he does so through the reflection
of a mirror.
“I am the man you call Jigsaw.”
Could he be doing this because he’s looking
into the past, looking back in the rearview
at the old Hoffman who has not yet been reborn
as a disciple of Jigsaw?
Is that too deep for a Saw movie?
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Also in this workshop, I spotted one of those
Chinese figurines, from beside John’s deathbed
in Saw 3 and the New Years festival in Saw
4.
Strahm would continue to go through old files
to dig out more and more about Mark Hoffman’s
past, where he would page past a curious detail
that could have changed the context of crimes
that took place all the way back in the first
Saw film.
As Strahm goes through the old case files
from the Razor Wire Trap’s victim, Paul
Leahy, you may notice that Detective Hoffman
was actually the lead investigator on it.
When we see that crime scene back in the first
movie, it’s Sing, Tapp and Kerry, who has
not yet been promoted to detective.
There’s no sign of Hoffman at all.
I don’t know if that means he had already
investigated it and these other guys were
coming to take a second look, or if he was
calling the shots and asked Sing and Tapp
to make their own assessment, perhaps to lead
them down the path to Jigsaw with a plan to
take them out.
The files seen earlier on list Hoffman, Tapp
and Sing as the investigators on the case,
and it seems to be the first Jigsaw case any
of them worked on from what we can see there,
though I should add that there are other Jigsaw
murders that aren’t listed here or shown
in any movie, but I’m not gonna talk about
that in this video.
We’ll probably never solve the mystery of
Hoffman’s involvement in the Paul Leahy
case.
Saw 5 also has another ambiguous question
which comes up when Jill Tuck meets with Erickson
at the FBI headquarters claiming that she
believes the Bureau is following her.
“I think it’s the Agent who interrogated
me.”
“Agent Strahm?”
The strange thing is, we never see this happen.
In fact, we see Strahm laser-focused on investigating
Hoffman, paying no attention to Jill.
I guess it is possible that she was told to
do this by John as part of his instructions
for her after his death, but I’ve come to
think there is another possibility.
In Saw 6, we see she has made contact with
Hoffman, who is actively trying to get rid
of Strahm and make him look like the unknown
accomplice.
I think there’s a possibility that Hoffman
instructed Jill to bring up these concerns
with Erickson; maybe he even threatened her
to get what he wants.
I don’t see any other reason for her to
go to him, unless she’s just trying to get
a job at the Daily Bugle.
"You serious?"
Maybe it was all part of Hoffman’s plan
to frame Special Agent Strahm.
He does so by leaving a Strahm’s phone in
his lair at the catacombs where the Fiendish
Five’s game took place.
OK, not the Fiendish Five, the Fatal Five.
That’s what they’re called.
"You know, that Thingus Racamagoocus had a lot of nice pictures,
but way too many big words."
So he led J Jonah Jameson to believe Strahm
was guilty, while leading Strahm to a seemingly
inconspicuous house.
A house that is the last house on the left
side of it’s street.
With a light on the left and a storage area
on the right.
A house with a small door underneath the stairs.
A house whose halls have a very familiar layout.
Could this location be the infamous Nerve
Gas House which was the venue of the main
game seen in Saw 2?
It’s definitely very similar in layout,
right down to the room that contained the
safe, with a trap door in the same spot leading
down to the underground tunnel network, which
appears to be the very same tunnel network
that contains the bathroom, judging by the
inclusion of this sliding door.
We know that John was a civil engineer once
involved in a major housing project and he
does have access to multiple properties.
In Saw 2 we see him utilize both the Nerve
Gas House and the Fake-Out House with a seemingly
similar layout.
We also know that the project was supposed
to provide housing to 40 low-income families,
so it seems reasonable that each of these
units was based on the same design, and they
may each have the same layout.
I have to admit, it doesn’t really make
sense for John or Hoffman to pull off a major
renovation of the dilapidated Nerve Gas House
just for this one small moment.
I’m not really even sure that they could
fix up the entire house in such a short time
frame, especially given all they accomplished
between October 2005 and April 2006, and Saw
5 takes place not too long after, most likely
in July 2006.
Maybe these houses were all placed on a grid,
so that there were several houses on the left
side at the end of their respective streets.
That would put the Hoffman House in the same
neighborhood as the Nerve Gas House and The
Fake-Out House, which would make it plausible
that it could be connected to the same tunnel
network that contains both The Bathroom and
the Glass Coffin room.
And we know that it’s the same tunnel network,
because Strahm finds a big red streak, which
we learn the origin of in Saw 7 when we see
the quote unquote “extended version” of
Gordon’s escape from The Bathroom after
Saw 1.
Like I mentioned earlier, this might just
be one of those Saw mysteries that can never
be fully explained, forever being discussed
in the comments, although I think there is
more of a chance that this location could
be revisited in a future movie, so maybe one
day we’ll find out.
The safe room is also full of easter eggs,
and I’m not even talking about this clown
that is basically identical to that one clown
in Beverly’s house in the 2017 version of
It.
The room contains more of those Chinese figures,
the pig ornament from Jeff Denlon’s study,
and several wood mannequins, a connection
to the many mannequins John used to test his
traps on, dating back to the old Stygian Street
hideout in an old mannequin factory.
So Hoffman’s plan, at least for now, works.
J Jonah Erickson finds Strahm’s phone in
the catacombs at the site of the game, and
Strahm falls victim to the collapsing walls
of The Glass Coffin Trap.
At the beginning of this video I mentioned
the Pendulum, which was also the titular device
in Edgar Allen Poe’s short story, The Pit
and Pendulum.
To bring that connection full circle, Saw
5’s final trap represents The Pit.
As written by Poe himself:
“Its centre, and of course, its greatest
width, came just over the yawning gulf.
I shrank back -- but the closing walls pressed
me resistlessly onward.
At length for my seared and writhing body
there was no longer an inch of foothold on
the firm floor of the prison.
I struggled no more, but the agony of my soul
found vent in one loud, long, and final scream
of despair.”
While this would be the end of Strahm, his
legacy would live on in the sequel, so join
me in the next episode for even more Things
You Missed in Saw 6.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.